all seeing evil eyes teddy bears bent on
murder and of course the end of the
world but which billion dollar movie was
the best
the fourth film in the transformers
franchise age of extinction added
hollywood star mark wahlberg which
helped reinvigorate the series in the
film a new villain emerges called
lockdown a transformer bounty hunter who
has come to earth to kill optimus prime
unfortunately the film quickly devolves
confusing large-scale battle scenes and
a mess of mind-numbing cgi which to be
fair is kind of the whole transformer
style fans burned out by age of
extinction's excesses failed to turn up
for the sequel effectively ending the
franchise
released in 2011 dark of the moon is the
final transformers film to feature
original series star shia labeouf in the
film it's revealed that the original
apollo mission to the moon in 1969 was
actually a covert reconnaissance mission
that uncovered a massive cybertronian
starship the robot inside ends up
betraying the autobots threatening to
tip the balance of power in their cosmic
war once again michael bay worked his
magic assembling a surprisingly high
caliber supporting cast of stars
including john malkovich and frances
mcdormand heck there was even an
appearance from actual apollo 11
astronaut national hero buzz aldrin and
from a fellow space traveler it's a true
honor the honor is mine
but ultimately the film was let down by
an overwatch story and over-the-top
spectacle that bludgeons rather than
delights
loosely inspired by a mostly unrelated
novel also named on stranger tides the
fourth pirates of the caribbean film
sees captain jack sparrow reunite with a
former flame who delivers sparrow into
the clutches of the dreaded blackbeard
the mission locate the fabled fountain
of youth with a ship full of zombified
pirates despite a promising premise
though the movie doesn't live up to the
chills and thrills of earlier entries in
the series they received poor reviews
from fans and critics alike causing the
sequel dead men tell no tales to sink on
arrival ending the jack sparrow saga as
we know it despite his master plan to
save it we shall need a crossbow an
hourglass three goats one of us must
learn to play the trumpet whilst the
other one goes like this
to its credit jurassic world fallen
kingdom attempts to do something
different than its predecessor jurassic
world after the island goes awry our
heroes gather the dinosaurs and move
them to a new sanctuary at lockwood
manor residents of jurassic park's
original secretive co-founder benjamin
lockwood but it turns out that
lockwood's minions have other more
sinister plans for the dinosaurs
disjointed and disappointing it coasted
on its big bold action scenes and the
love audiences still had for the
jurassic park franchise but critics and
audiences alike were unimpressed feeling
the film lacked the thrills and chills
of the movies that came before it
set decades before the original star
wars trilogy star wars episode 1 the
phantom menace follows veteran jedi
knight qui-gon jinn and his protege
obi-wan kenobi as they uncover a
conspiracy on the far-off planet naboo
which sets in motion a terrible chain of
events that viewers knew would
ultimately lead to the rise of the evil
empire the phantom menace expanded the
galaxy with new additions like liam
neeson ewan mcgregor and natalie portman
and some cool action scenes
unfortunately that couldn't save the
film from stiff dialogue and backlash on
characters like jar jar binks monsters
out there leaking in here all sinking in
all power when the user thinking lisa in
trouble
the first in a new wave of disney live
action remakes the 2010 big budget
blockbuster alice in wonderland was led
by celebrated director tim burton who
assembled a cast of stars to bring his
mad retelling of the classic children's
story to life the film wasn't without
its critics who in particular called out
its generic climax but with its talented
cast outrageous style and eccentric
visuals audiences largely embraced the
film helping spur disney to create a
slew of live-action remakes in the
decade that followed
after a divisive fan reaction to the
second of disney star wars sequel
trilogy ryan johnson's the last jedi jj
abrams was rushed back into the
director's chair for star wars episode 9
the rise of skywalker the result was an
ambitious but haphazard attempt to tie
together four decades of continuity in a
way that was satisfying for obsessed
fans and some fans were happy to get any
answers to long-standing questions and
resolutions to ongoing character arcs
not to mention some breakneck action
unfortunately critics were less than
enthused and largely knocked the film
for messy script choppy storytelling and
one too many confusing plot points
in despicable me 3 lovable former
supervillain grew now works as an agent
for the anti-villain league tracking
down other baddies and thwarting their
evil schemes when a job goes wrong gru
is fired from the abl even losing his
beloved minions in the process but just
when he's struggling with what to do
next he comes face to face with his
long-lost twin brother drew who wants
lessons on how to be a super villain and
it doesn't go great i should have stayed
in the boat
my stomach feels all queasy i shouldn't
have eaten that pot pie
though a massive hit in theaters
despicable me 3 split audiences and
critics who felt it was a little too
much of the same
going into this live-action remake of
the beloved 1994 animated classic the
lion king many were skeptical that
director jon favreau could bring
anything new to the table but the result
was a lush visual feast with audiences
eating up the awe-inspiring cgi visuals
created using innovative and
groundbreaking new virtual filmmaking
techniques critics however were
dismissive of what they considered a
soulless lackluster remake of an
indelible original even the return of
the legendary james earl jones as king
mufasa wasn't enough to elevate the
final film one day somehow the sun will
set on my time here
and will rise with you as the new king
the breakout stars of the despicable me
franchise the pint-sized overall wearing
yellow beans called minions got their
own movie in the wake of despicable me
2. a prequel to the first despicable me
the minions movie gives audiences the
secret origin of the little pill-shaped
people as we follow their origins from
single-celled organisms all the way up
to them meeting the supervillain grew
taking the minions out of despicable me
and putting them into their own mini
franchise could have gone terribly wrong
over the cast of impeccable voice actors
including sandra bullock and jon hamm it
worked surprisingly well
after the blockbuster success of other
live-action remakes disney looked to
their 1992 film aladdin for their next
big hit before the 2019 live-action
version even arrived though it was mired
in controversy over the way star will
smith looked when animated as a
cgi-enhanced blue genie but once aladdin
landed in theaters audiences turned out
in droves to see the sprawling fantasy
epic fans gave the young cast high marks
for infusing their characters with
hearts and earnestness but critics
panned the film once again questioning
what the point of these live-action
remakes was
aquaman released in 2018 opens with the
origin of dc's famous seafaring
superhero the son of a lighthouse
captain and a stranded woman from
atlantis young arthur curry is left to
be raised on land ultimately wanting no
part of his watery legacy but when a
villain threatens war with the surface
world curry must finally confront his
destiny in order to stop them led by
jason momoa nicole kidman and willem
dafoe the all-star cast gave the film
major acting talent to go with a pumped
up action spectacle from director james
wan reigns however could be safely shut
off for the duration of the run time
pinocchio
you risked our lives based on something
you read in a children's book
it's a book
the eighth film in the long-running fast
and the furious series the fate of the
furious reunited stars vin diesel and
dwayne the rock johnson in a battle with
newcomer charlize theron as the villain
cipher in this installment of the
seemingly never ending franchise dom
toretto's retirement is upended when
he's blackmailed into working for the
baddies the old crew must band together
to discover why toretto has seemingly
turned villain with some shocking twists
and new revelations fate of the furious
continued upping the ante with even
bigger and bolder action sequences than
ever before
based on the original book by j.r.r
tolkien the hobbiton unexpected journey
expands greatly on the story we meet a
homebody hobbit named bilbo as he is
recruited by gandalf on a quest to help
a group of determined dwarves to find a
lost treasure along the way he picks up
a little gold ring that will one day
change the fate of all middle earth with
peter jackson back at the helm an
unexpected journey is full of delightful
adventure overfull in fact it's also
bloated and indulgent leading to a
flabby viewing experience that turned
off fans and critics alike
the 2017 live action remake of the 1991
adaptation of the 18th century french
fairy tale beauty and the beast brought
the fantasy starring harry potter's emma
watson and luke evans of the hobbit and
it tells the same story you go in
expecting to see belle's father is taken
prisoner by a beast she exchanges places
with him and unexpected love ensues once
again disney pulled out all the stops
loading the film up on luscious eye
candy and top-rate cinematography that
dazzled moviegoers earning it impressive
reviews to go with a wave of comforting
nostalgia it's not often that a sequel
can reach the height of its predecessor
but frozen 2 broke the mold releasing in
2019 to rave reviews and ultimately
becoming nearly as beloved as 2013's
original frozen frozen 2 is another
frosty musical tale that reveals the
secret origin of elsa's powers and the
truth behind the death of her parents
funny romantic bittersweet the film
mixes every emotion with gorgeous 3d
animation while somehow telling a more
nuanced and complex drama than the first
without feeling weighted down or
overstuffed with story it's a testament
to disney's finest storytellers that
they were able to recapture the magic of
frozen
robert downey jr returned in 2013's iron
man 3 as tony stark now dealing with the
traumatic after effects of the alien
invasion shown in 2012's avengers but he
also has to deal with a new threat in
the form of a notorious global criminal
kingpin called the mandarin who turns
out to not exactly be what he seems
killian he created you he created me
custom-made terror threat
yes
with some of the best iron man action to
date the excitement and drama was all
there with some added heart and depth
thanks to writer director shane black
still the surprising twist regarding the
mandarin's true nature riled a lot of
fans leaving many with decidedly mixed
feelings
after the overwhelming success of 2015
star wars episode vii the force awakens
disney turned the keys of the franchise
over to looper director ryan johnson for
the sequel he succeeded in taking the
franchise in a bold new direction with
star wars episode viii the last jedi for
many viewers though it was the wrong
direction as rey discovers that the
legendary luke skywalker has given up
and become a mopey cynic adding the
slowest chase scene in sci-fi history
and a general disregard for everything
that happened in the previous film and
you end up with a movie that was
appreciated more by critics than fans
2012's avengers was a massive success so
for the 2015 sequel avengers age of
ultron marvel brought back everyone
including director joss whedon and then
they stuffed it full of even more
characters introducing the vision
quicksilver and scarlet witch to help
battle the new threat to the monstrous
robot ultron while some fans praised the
action and character moments in the film
others felt age of ultron was a bit
bogged down by excessive world building
at the expense of the story the world it
built though would help take the mcu to
undreamt heights
not many franchises make it to seven
films but the truly amazing thing about
furious 7 is that it nearly doubled the
box office of fast and furious 6 turning
the popular series into an absolute unit
in the film dom toretto and his crew
were confronted by jason statham's
deckard shaw the vengeance seeking
brother of fast and furious six villain
owen shaw the movie was also the final
entry for series star paul walker who
was tragically killed in an unrelated
car accident while the film was in
production thanks to the cooperation of
his family and a little cgi magic
producers were able to complete his
performance and give the actor a
touching send-off that proved an
emotional moment for fans
2003's pirates of the caribbean the
curse of the black pearl proved
audiences would turn out for a movie
based on a disney theme park ride and
the 2006 sequel dead man's chest proved
audiences couldn't get enough of johnny
depp's antics as captain jack sparrow
in this one will is ordered to help find
jack and in turn the fabled dead man's
chest at the request of the corrupt lord
beckett all while fighting off the
legendary davy jones and his mystical
pirate ship the flying dutchman so big
it couldn't get out of its own way dead
man's chest set the franchise on a
course for the many hits that followed
in 2016 star wars went where it had
never gone before releasing a standalone
live-action theatrical film set outside
of the main saga rogue one a star wars
story told the story of how the
rebellion in a new hope got the death
star plans to begin with with recruits
jyn erso and cassian andor leading a
suicide mission to set the stage for the
fall of the empire a darker grittier
take on the franchise rogue one was
celebrated for its grittier take on the
mythos and has been lauded by some
hardcore fans as the best of the recent
star wars films
released in 2009 the sci-fi adventure
avatar left viewers jaws on the floor
with its immersive vision of a far-off
alien world the film is centered on a
race of blue skinned natives called the
navi as their home is invaded by greedy
corporate mercenaries who want to steal
their resources
filmed using a new groundbreaking 3d
technology avatar approved a movie going
experience unlike any other driving fans
into theaters in numbers nobody had ever
thought possible more than a decade
later it's still the top grossing film
of all time
the third in director christopher
nolan's trilogy the dark knight rises
finished off what many consider to be
the greatest comic book movie series
ever produced set almost a decade after
the previous film rizes finds bruce
wayne retired when a new and more
insidious villain called bane shows up
on the scene when bane's plot to destroy
gotham proves too much for him he's
forced to sacrifice everything to save
the city well for many the dark knight
rises could never live up to the dark
knight it still remained a satisfying
and action-packed conclusion to the
three film saga neatly tying the whole
story together
the 2019 sci-fi superhero actioner
captain marvel was the first mcu film of
the woman lead the film was set in the
1990s when a valiant space ranger crash
lands on earth and discovers she's
actually a human woman named carol
danvers with the help of a younger nick
fury danvers must recover her lost
memories and uncover the truth behind
the conflict between two warring alien
races
fans expectations for the film were so
high that they proved impossible to meet
but captain marvel remains a solid entry
in the mcu and better than it's often
given credit for
after the original jurassic park trilogy
petered out in 2001 it would be 14 years
before jurassic world rebooted the
franchise the 2015 tent poll brought in
new stars chris pratt and bryce dallas
howard for a story about you guessed it
dinosaurs running rampant through a
tropical island theme park only this
time the park is filled with thousands
of tourists for maximum carnage debuting
with good reviews from both critics and
audiences jurassic world was lauded for
its successful mix of modern thrills and
classic jurassic park storytelling
ultimately leading to two sequels of its
own
the first film to ever earn a billion
dollars at the box office 1997's titanic
featured leonardo dicaprio and kate
winslet as star cross lovers jack and
rose the poor jack and the rich rose
find true love just as the doomed ship
famously strikes an iceberg and pulls
most of the film's all-star cast
straight to the bottom
[Music]
this is where we first met
a tale of love lust betrayal and revenge
set against the backdrop of one of
history's greatest ocean disasters the
film has something for everyone it's no
wonder it has remained a beloved classic
for a quarter of a century
director todd phillips turned 2019's the
joker into a gritty and grounded
psychological drama and an incisive and
surprising takedown of modern life
touching on such weighty issues as the
mental health system and wealth
inequality star joaquin phoenix turned
the clown face to supervillain into a
deeply troubled soul who resorts to
violence when society turns its back on
him the result struck a chord with
audiences who flocked to see the timely
film despite few action scenes and
almost no big special effects
unsurprisingly a sequel was announced in
2022 and is already in the works
the 2019 blockbuster spider-man far from
home didn't just build on the legacy of
the previous six spider-man films it
also provided the first follow-up to the
cataclysmic events of the mcu defining
avengers end game the story about peter
dealing with grief after the loss of
mentor tony stark and a surprising
betrayal by new mentor mysterio allowed
fans to process their own feelings of
grief over the death of iron man mixing
coming-of-age teen drama with
high-stakes superhero action far from
home showed that the mcu was now
centered around a new figure and
spider-man was up to the task based on
the series of hit young adult fantasy
novels 2001's harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone introduces audiences to
a young orphaned boy sent to attend
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry there he meets new friends who
help him discover the truth when a
terrible evil begins threatening him in
the school we know about the soldier's
stone
oh
well the film wasn't as refined or slick
as its successors would be it drew
audiences of all ages with its fantasy
thrills family-friendly adventure and
magical mystery and turn unknown child
actors daniel radcliffe emma watson and
rupert grint into international stars
another blockbuster from the mcu 2016's
captain america civil war saw the
avengers dealing with the aftermath of a
mission gone wrong when cap's old
sidekick bucky now the winter soldier is
accused of killing the wakandan king our
heroes are forced to choose just whose
side they're on caps or iron mans in
addition to bringing back old favorites
the film introduced two big new players
for the first time chadwick boseman
makes his first appearance as the black
panther while marvel also introduced
spider-man into the mcu between the big
superhero debuts the over-the-top hero
on hero action this one was a crowd
pleaser
based on the novel by author michael
crichton 1993's jurassic park was
quickly optioned for a big budget
feature film by none other than steven
spielberg he ditched the books hard
science in favor of an awe-inspiring
adventure with groundbreaking special
effects that made dinosaurs more real
than ever before your scientists were so
preoccupied with whether or not they
could they didn't stop to think they
should
when dinosaurs are cloned hero
scientists sam neal laura dern and jeff
goldblum have to stop them from running
amok one of the most thrilling and
unexpected big screen joyrides in movie
history on its release audiences and
critics were in awe of the movie billed
as 65 million years in the making they
could do it and it turned out they
should
in an unparalleled and monumental
undertaking the fledgling marvel studios
set out to craft the first ever true
cinematic universe after the film's iron
man the incredible hulk captain america
and thor introduced the individual
heroes 2012's the avengers brought them
all together in a way never seen in
movies before the story stopped loki and
his alien army from conquering earth a
sharply written slickly executed action
blockbuster not a moment is wasted in
the superhero adventure which thrilled
audiences and set the stage for a decade
at box office dominance by marvel
it all came to this 2021's spider-man no
way home brought back characters from
all seven previous sony and marvel
spider-man films as the spider-man of
three universes banded together to try
and save the mcu's peter parker from his
own mistakes fans thrilled to see toby
mcguire and andrew garfield stand
shoulder to shoulder with tom holland as
they fought a menagerie of villains from
all three realities with enough easter
eggs and guest stars to force fans into
theaters despite a global pandemic no
way home proved one of the biggest crowd
pleasers marvel has ever produced
loosely inspired by hans christian
andersen's the snow queen 2013's frozen
centers on elsa who fears her own icy
supernatural powers and has grown
estranged from her younger sister anna
as a result but when elsa unwittingly
unleashes her powers and covers the
kingdom in an icy winter anna must
rekindle their relationship to save
everyone
with memorable musical numbers and a
timeless story of family frozen became
an instant classic crossing age and
gender lines it was beloved by audiences
of all stripes helping it become an
unexpected billion dollar hit
2003's finding nemo was a massive
blockbuster and an instant family
classic but it would be more than a
decade before pixar followed up with
2016's finding dory which follows nemo's
forgetful friend dory as she sets out to
regain her memory and find her long-lost
parents and along the way she inevitably
meets a host of new animated undersea
buddies finding dory was the rare sequel
to be not only a bigger earner than its
predecessor but an equally
crowd-pleasing film as fans and critics
alike praised it for its heartwarming
story
2004's the incredibles was one of
pixar's most beloved films so it's no
surprise that fans turned out in droves
for the 2018 sequel the incredibles 2.
after the fallout from the first film's
climactic battle the government shuts
down their superhero program but when a
wealthy tycoon offers mr incredible and
elastigirl the chance to become heroes
again they jump at the chance only for
elastigirl to uncover a sinister plot to
end all superheroes for good with loads
of superhero action delightful comedy
and classic pixar hearts incredibles 2
is a hit in every sense of the word
for a full decade audiences watched
harry potter hermione granger and ron
weasley grow up on screen as they fought
to stop the return of the wizarding
world's greatest villain lord voldemort
it all culminated in 2011's harry potter
and the deathly hallows part 2 as the
8th and final film in the series saw our
heroes take on voldemort's army in the
battle of hogwarts deathly hallows part
2 was not only the highest grossing film
in the franchise it was also the most
critically acclaimed earning three
academy award nominations and a 96 on
rotten tomatoes they truly saved the
best for last
after disney bought the rights to star
wars in 2012 it was inevitable that new
movies were coming the first was 2015
star wars episode vii the force awaken
which brought back original characters
han leia and luke and paired them with a
new generation of heroes in the form of
rey finn and poe while it was knocked
for being something of a rehash fans
loved the familiar and critics praised
the picture for re-energizing the
franchise with a promising new story
set in a world of anthropomorphic
talking animals 2016's animated smash
zootopia features judy hopps an upbeat
bunny who enlists in the local police
force through a series of mishaps she
winds up stuck with nick wilde a jaded
foxconn artist who wants anything but to
be paired with hops they soon uncover a
major conspiracy that threatens the city
and must work together to get to the
truth mixing elements from the best
buddy cop comedies with the charms of
the best animated family films zootopia
ultimately won the academy award for
best animated film
combining every major marvel franchise
with heroes from the avengers the
guardians of the galaxy and the recently
incorporated spider-man 2018's avengers
infinity war saw thanos arrive on earth
to complete his collection of infinity
stones the powerful ancient relics that
will give him the power to wipe out half
of all life in the universe an edge of
your seat thrill ride from start to
finish the movie managed to mix dozens
of heroes and villains together in a
story with a vast canvas it satisfied
fans of every character and delivered
something bolder and bigger than anyone
imagined subverting expectations with a
twist ending that left audiences gasping
in disbelief
after 50 years and 23 films 2012 skyfall
marked the first james bond movie to
crack the billion dollar mark in the
darkest installment yet a critical
mission goes wrong and mi6 is
compromised daniel craig's bond is the
only agent left that can be trusted and
is tasked with tracking down and
stopping a madman named silva an
insidious threat from m's past to his
comeback for revenge buoyed by newcomers
like rape fines the film was a tight
gripping spy thriller of the highest
caliber and many fans and critics still
consider it the high point of modern
bond films
released in 2019 toy story 4 was an
unexpected sequel as a beloved franchise
was seemingly over for good luckily it
wasn't while on a road trip with their
new owner woody is reunited with his old
flame bo peep who tries to get him to
run away with her now woody must decide
whether he wants a future with a child
as he has always believed was intended
or the freedom of a new life as a rogue
toy once again pixar knocked it out of
the park with fans and critics alike now
the only question is whether there will
ever be a toy story 5.
combining lush vibrant and expressive
animation with a number of iconic new
songs and powerful storytelling 1994's
the lion king was a worldwide sensation
in this animated shakespearean tragedy
young cub prince simba runs in fear
after his uncle scar murders his father
king mufasa but when simba's childhood
friend nala finds him he is urged to
return to the pride and save his former
home from the cruelty of his uncle one
of the most acclaimed and beloved films
of all time the lion king has enjoyed
multiple re-releases over the years to
help it cross the billion dollar mark
marvel comics first black superhero
debuted 1966 in the pages of fantastic
four but it would take until 2017 for
black panther to get his own feature
film expectations were through the roof
but even the most fervent fans were
blown away by director ryan coogler's
vision of afrofuturism but it was actor
chadwick boseman who provided the heart
to this story which centers around a
challenge to the ideologies of wakanda
by t'challa's cousin killmonger
tragically bozeman passed away in 2020
at the age of 43 leaving an indelible
legacy behind
2008's the dark knight is one of the
most critically acclaimed superhero
films of all time heath ledger stars as
the joker who sets out to prove humanity
isn't worth saving by exposing all the
hypocrisy greed and selfishness beneath
the surface of gotham city directed by
christopher nolan and starring christian
bale as batman the dark knight was a
tour de force tragically star heath
ledger died just months before release
but he'd get the last lap on his
doubters as his performance earned him a
posthumous oscar
36 years after the original top gun
debuted in theaters 2022's top gun
maverick blew audiences expectations out
of the sky with the return of tom
cruise's legendary fight pilot pete
maverick mitchell called back into
service to help train a group of young
recruits for a crucial mission behind
enemy lines maverick gets more than he
bargained for when he learns one of the
cadets as the son of his old friend
goose who died in an accident for which
he has long felt responsible my dad
believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
praised by critics top gun maverick
soared to become one of the best
reviewed films of the year and the best
of tom cruise's long career
the culmination of more than a decade of
films 2019's avengers end game might be
the most highly anticipated superhero
movie ever coming a year after infinity
war left fans stunned by thanos victory
and the loss of half of our heroes
avengers endgame sees the surviving
heroes engage in a desperate time heist
to try and alter reality itself but
thanos has other plans only stopped when
tony stark sacrifices himself to save
the entire universe from oblivion
featuring action on a scale never before
imagined end game was the ultimate
theater experience for an entire
generation
coming out a decade after toy story 2
2010's toy story 3 sees the toys from
andy's room mistakenly donated to a
daycare center where the plush
monstrosity lotso hugging bear rules
with terror woody buzz and the rest must
band together to lead a toy rebellion in
order to save themselves from certain
doom receiving universal critical
acclaim toy story 3 served as a perfect
conclusion to the story of woody buzz in
the game
of course another sequel eventually
followed and a fifth may be on the way
but toy story 3 still remains the best
reviewed film of the series
the lord of the rings the return of the
king capped off the epic fantasy film
trilogy from director peter jackson in
2003 the final film in the series sees
sam and frodo making their final journey
to the steps of mount doom while aragorn
gandalf and an army of men confront
sauron's forces in a final showdown
between the forces of good and evil a
box office smash return of the king put
a perfect bow in the lord of the rings
film saga not only is it the highest
grossing film in the series and also
took home the academy award for best
picture the only fantasy film to ever do
so
you bow to no one
[Music]